dotted throughout Poland there were
hundreds and I mean hundreds of
extermination camps and these were small
camps where the trains that brought the
prisoners you lasted about a month and
15,000 Czech and Slovak children died in
concentration
[Music]
camps
I was born in Prague but as a family we
lived in a small village my own mother
died when I was 3 years old and
eventually my father remarried and um my
stepmother was a doctor that um she was
always my my mother and that's where we
lived that was in
1937 well of course by
1939 um I personally had no idea what
was going on in Europe but Hitler had
already occupied Austria
there'd already been this Dreadful
Munich agreement which Chamberlain
attended where they finally Hitler said
he wanted to occupy certain parts of uh
the Czech
Republic on the border of Germany and uh
he basically promised that if they could
occupy that area of the country he'd
leave the rest alone so chamin came back
and said great there's not going to be a
war you know we've made
agreement but of course that was all a
liee because on the um 14th of March
1939 uh the Nazis occupy the rest of the
country do you have any memory of that I
have absolutely no memory of that at all
what I do know that my father was
involved with a very famous German
author called Thomas man
back in the 30s Thomas man had written
some very unpleasant
antii articles and books and he was
expelled from Germany so in
1939 these two men came to see my father
saying by tomorrow Prague will be
occupied your name is high on the list
to be arrested by the guest Apper and we
suggest that you leave I just know he
disappeared we didn't
know our our parents never talked about
this my mother you know didn't discuss
this with us I was a 9-year-old my
sister was three and then in May that
year she told us that we were going to
go to
England there hadd already been a Kinder
transport in
1938 when
10,000 Austrian and German children had
been brought to England and that was the
Kinder transport but in
1939 is when the
Germans started you know when when the
when
um the occupation
began and uh the the the Czech Jewish
families were beginning to realize how
dangerous life was going to be and put
the children on the train on the 31st of
um
July I was taken with my sister to the
railway
station and my grandfather came with us
and it was there that he gave me my
autograph book in which he sent a
message wrote a message um and in the
message he said remember to stay
faithful to the country you're leaving
to your grandfather to your parents who
love you very
much and we were then put on the
train this is this is the label I
actually wore around my neck and it's
got British committee CH child transport
with Flashman Miller and my number was
641 and my sisters were
639 I can't honestly remember you know
being on the train traveling on that
train except I was with my sister and
with us was also my two and a
half-year-old little cousin that was
also traveling called Helen whose father
mother had also escaped and he was
already in England he joined the uh
Czech Air Force so he was waiting for
her when when she got to England we
traveled to
Holland um on Route although the train
stopped we couldn't get out uh to buy
any food uh we had to have everything
with us but we got to Holland and
Holland at that point was still free and
we were met at the
station um and I know by you know Dutch
people who are expecting this train with
these children given um I was told hot
chocolate drink I was told bananas my
sister said she was sick but she can't
possibly remember because she was three
but and then we were put on this huge
ship now none of us had ever seen the
sea
Czechoslovakia is right in the center of
Europe and the biggest thing we saw were
would be Lakes however
um we traveled with the ship to harch
where there was another train waiting
for us to take us to Liverpool Street
Station and there were the various
foster parents waiting to collect the
children uh these parents that had been
found by This Man Called Nicholas
Winton
we were met by a couple called um well
he only he came uh we got to know him
eventually his daddy Ratcliffe he was
called Roland Ratcliffe and he lived in
Ashton underline um small town near
Manchester and daddy Ratcliffe was the
Secretary of the local local labor party
and he took us on the train uh to live
with
them and we went to live in 72 Alexandra
Street and this was a a two up two down
Terrace
house um two bedrooms bath in the
kitchen l in the yard a front
room and we had come from prag from a
very modern
apartment but from what I know and what
I remember it didn't we didn't seem to
mind and the rat Cliffs had a daughter a
16-year-old daughter called Mary and
because they didn't want to separate us
because a lot of the children who came
the siblings were separated from each
other they sent Mary to live with their
grandmother so they could uh have both
of us in the in the
bedroom and uh they were extremely kind
to us and um uh as opposed to people
talking about English food we had
absolutely no problem M ratri was a very
good cook and you know you remember
things through remembering food and I
remember things like plum pie and uh
Yorkshire pudding with with um um syrup
on it and I went to the local school
Mosley Road Council
school um I've got a report somewhere
and I must have been speaking English
very quickly and from photographs of the
time we look very
happy at what point did you begin to
understand what had happened to you all
the time when we were small our parents
never talked about it now we knew the
war was on but of course nobody knew
well a few people we We Gather now did
know what was going on with
concentration camps but the general
public didn't we didn't we didn't know
that in
1942 when the um final solution that was
known that was organized when all the
Jewish population was being rounded up
and sent to either terine or in my case
in our case U my cousins and my
grandparents were sent directly to an
extermination camp of which there were
many that people don't realize people
know the name of aitz and bson but
dotted throughout Poland there were
hundreds and I mean hundreds of
extermination camps and these were small
camps where the trains that brought the
prisoners you lasted about a month and
you were immediately murdered in the Gus
Chambers and my cousins who were the
same ages who would have been at the
time
15 and 12 very
sadly uh they in
1942 with their parents were taken away
and uh to a concentration camp and from
the documents they they lasted just a
month before they were killed there so
most of my relations actually died in
the camps although I came out on the
last train there was another train je to
leave and this train was full of over
200 children and he was due to leave on
the 1st of
September and 1st of September
1939 is when the Germans invaded Poland
War started and that train never left
and
15,000 Czech and Slovak children died in
concentration camps and from that
train uh as far as we know we had news
of about four children that had survived
but all the others didn't and of course
we wouldn't have um if we hadn't if my
mother hadn't been brave enough to put
us on that
train can you discuss the first time
that you were told about the man who had
rescued you all those years ago the
first time was when um I got a phone
call at home in the
kitchen in
19 um what would it be 58 68 78
88 and this woman said this is Esther
Ranson and uh I thought somebody was
pulling my leg and I just said I'm the
Queen of England I literally answered
her that way and she said no what what
was your name before you were grle
Baines and I said it was Flashman she
said well I have a a list in my hand and
we found your name on there and and the
list comes from a scrap book which
belongs to a man called Nicholas Winton
and we're going to invite Mr Winton to
the television studio and we'd like you
to come down to meet him uh we're
inviting him a few of you I said yes
certainly um but I still had no idea
really what she was I I hadn't taken it
in and when I got to London and we got
to the studio she said now we're going
to ask this gentleman to come in we
don't want you to tell tell him who you
are this is to surprise him um but he's
the man who organized the trains that
you traveled on when you came to England
we were sitting on the front row and
there was an empty chair next to us and
um she sat nicking down there and the
program
started and uh she had this scrapbook
with her and she was saying now Mr
[Music]
um these are the pictures of some of the
children that you um you brought to
England and uh here is the list of names
and next to you that was on his left is
a woman called Vera she was called Vera
gissing and Vera flung her arms around
him and said thank you for saving my
life and I was sitting on his right hand
side and of course and then he she
introduced uced me to him and I happened
to have and I was able to tell him that
not only I was saved that my mother was
saved and when eser Anson said those of
you who came on the train will you stand
up the entire Studio stood up and there
you saw him slightly wiping his eyes he
wasn't an emotional man really at all if
you today go down any Street in the
Czech Republic and you tell them that
you're a winon child
every person in the country knows his
name when you met him how did you
feel well how do you feel when you meet
a man who saves your life and of course
he became almost a surrogate father
uncle grandfather to hundreds of these
children who by now had been married and
got families as he said by then he had a
family of over 5,000 children one of us
was living in Tel
Aviv and his name was Hugo maram and
Hugo was visiting Nikki and he said you
know Nikki um you're famous people know
about us but the heroes of all our
stories were really the parents who were
brave enough to put the children on the
trains um
because most of them probably knew they
would never see them again and we should
have a memorial to those parents and
Niki said and not before
time I have time for one more question
and it's it's quite a big one what would
you most want people to understand
about the events of the Holocaust and
take from hearing your story and stories
like yours well first of all I think it
needs to be repeated I think the film
needs to be shown in schools and I I
make a point of this personally and I
know there are few of us who are still
alive who go to schools who talk to
children who um uh AWI should be visited
and I do know that high schools now do
have um Holocaust Education and
take take young
people to see what
happens when something dreadfully goes
wrong and uh a country and certain
people take law into their own hands
what happened in those days must never
again be repeated and it must never ever
be
forgotten and when the Nazi party came
around collecting all the Jews my aunt
who stayed with us looked out and saw
what was going on she couldn't do
anything about my mother who by that
time was taken downstairs into the uh
Courtyard where they gathered all the
Jewish women